so i'm i'm just curious about
how you came to the subject matter leah
i mean what
brought you
gosh well i was in rwanda with chris
toohey um who also filmed blackfish
which i'm sure you guys know about as
well that premiered at sundance this
year and
chris and todd and i actually worked
together quite a bit on many projects
and chris and i before i met todd were
in rwanda on another project
we travel all over the world and
everywhere we go we try and hire some
local
crew and so we did that in rwanda and
the last day we were there we were on
our way to the airport and we're at
bourbon coffee and we're like so what
else do you guys do do you work around
here and they told us about hillywood
because they were part of the the team
and so
they told us about this idea you know
where five thousand people show up with
no shoes on who've never seen a movie
before to watch movies for the first
time in their own language
and um we were hooked you know we went
back to seattle and we're still thinking
about the idea you know a couple months
later and that was a sign to me that
that we should really try and make a
film about this
we were holding our workshops
in
rwanda
almost everybody who attended the
workshops
really had no idea
about how to make movies
and
one of the things that we had to do
myself and every all the academy
delegates had to do was really change
the
way that we spoke about movie movie
making because the participants didn't
really have
a vocabulary
uh a cinematic vocabulary so what we
ended up talking about was storytelling
and that was kind of a way
to to
reach the the the participants that we
were talking to and most definitely
there's there's so many stories to tell
they're like they said themselves i mean
we really wanted to give the filmmakers
a voice um which is why you won't see
any caucasians in this movie um
we don't have a narrator you know we and
that was a conscious decision because we
we really felt like in order for them
you know we had to practice what we
preach if we're gonna make a film about
filmmakers telling their own stories
then we needed to allow them to tell
their own stories and there's many many
more
we happened to profile these people for
specific reasons
but we were just back in july showing
the film at the festival there and
you know we're introduced to a whole
slew of other filmmakers in particular
female filmmakers who are
who are up and coming and and a couple
who are doing really well and and who we
want to support long term so we're
excited about that very good and todd
your uh your work uh all of your
beautiful graphic works and the
animation happened i imagine it happened
at
after you finished making the movie and
was a really great way of sort of tying
all linking all the various pieces
together
can you just tell me we wanted to do
something how you made that decision
yeah
we wanted to do something germane to the
filmmaking process and when we were on
the ground there um the first thing we
all did and they did
you know when you go to tell a story in
film is you bring out the pad of paper
and you start drawing a picture
and sequence your scenes and you know
there are many
sections where we needed bridges in the
film that that it would have been easy
to go to the archive and pull out you
know the footage of the genocide that
that everyone's seen a million times and
we i really had a strong feeling about
not doing that
and um wanted to to tell the history and
give it you know give it justice but
also
you know not dwell on those images and
maybe come up with something more
powerful by showing less
uh we approached bp's uh the business
council for peace who's based in new
york about a year ago because one of our
goals since the beginning of this
project was to really
help the filmmakers find work
so that they can sustain their careers
there's plenty of organizations that
continue to go into rwanda and write a
check or
donate a camera or you show them how to
use a camera but um then they leave
and
we
you know we really wanted to create
something that would outlast our film
and help them find work so we partnered
with bps
and the academy of motion pictures to
create a website called rwandafilm.org
we have stickers outside and i urge all
of you to check it out it's really
incredible and bps has done such an
amazing job leading the charge on this
website and
it's really like a linkedin for for east
african filmmakers right now it's mainly
rwandan filmmakers but i i have a
feeling it's gonna it's gonna spread but
we don't wanna run it from across the
world we want it to be run locally and
so we are looking for
support to do that so all the you had
several different narrators in the film
and i know you kind of do a summation
about what where they are today but it's
is that
is that where they are today are those
folks still
uh is there is there an update on on the
lives of people july update july update
uh
we screened when we were there in july
we went to the countryside and screened
um
the films and also
there is a new theater in in kigali now
it's state-of-the-art theater uh which
it's pretty interesting to go to a
theater in in kigali where people
don't really know
how to go to a movie i mean it's people
are on their phones the whole time and
they show up a half hour late and leave
a half hour early and it's very funny
but um both richmond and rodrigue walked
into the movie
and sat down behind us and uh for us to
listen to rodriguez sitting behind us
crying through the whole movie he was
extremely emotional about it his
emotional guy anyway but um
uh he had just gotten married the day
before um
uh richmond has uh
uh was at the time we were filming with
him he was an editor at a pop magazine
and that has since
ended and now he is a full-time
filmmaker which was really nice he's
sustaining himself as a filmmaker he
just directed a documentary
it was it for me it was really fast
again getting back to this point it was
really fascinating being
there and working with a group of people
who who don't go to movies every day i
mean i think we take that for granted of
having this ex you know it's in our
lives it's something that we do
and
it's just it's just something it's part
of what we do but when you're
it was fascinating for me to be
surrounded by a group of people who were
appreciative of the fact that we were
there but they really had no sense of of
that we were these accomplished
filmmakers but we were there to share
our ideas and our thoughts
and to
share our approach to making movies with
all of them
so there was no vocabulary there and
there's no
a tradition of going to the movies film
economy as they like to call it now is
is getting quite competitive and there's
uh
something called the african digital
media academy um that is pretty
incredible they're they have
state-of-the-art equipment they are
teaching people how to do
really technical post-production skills
like rotoscoping and
these guys are making films we're also
focusing on story focusing on story and
they're building a little green screen
studio which has never been
done in rwanda and um they're gonna
they're
definitely a group to watch in the next
couple years they're doing some amazing
work
it's quickly become savvy we had we
spent two days
uh teaching workshops with eight women
who
totally
got it who totally they cranked out a
movie for their closing ceremony in in
the two days that we spent with them and
i think that was our emphasis there when
we were there as well i mean finally you
know when we realized that you we
couldn't talk about camera angles or or
our editing techniques we really uh
there was a
we there was a discussion amongst the
academy members about how do you solve
these problems how do you talk about
films and again finally we came back to
the idea that what we had to do
was to to really talk about story toy
storytelling where do you get the
stories from
do you get it from your parents do you
do you get it from folk tales
uh you know so
it really
trying to get people to understand how
important storytelling was
as a foundation for making films